[Music]
hi welcome to digital defense our weekly
cybersecurity show here from Bloomberg's
washington DC news bureau my name is
jordan robertson a cybersecurity
reporter for bloomberg and as always on
this weekly show this is an interactive
show so we encourage anybody watching
eat on Facebook or YouTube or any other
channels to write in with your questions
and and we will try to answer as many of
them as we can this week's subject you
know we're going to return to election
hacking but we're not going to look at
the u.s. we're going to look at Germany
and we're starting to see the the early
signs of essentially kind of a repeat of
what we saw in the US elections in
regard to Russian hacking and Russian
tampering I should say suspected russian
hacking and tampering and so I want to
walk you all through kind of what some
of those early signs are you know that
we're seeing out of Germany yeah what it
might mean for their elections in 2017
and you know really what it means
overall the big picture you know
regarding Russian influence in
cyberspace you know and how certain
cyber weapons and information operations
are being used to shape to shape foreign
policy you know in the US and Europe so
we'll dive right in i mean as everybody
you know knows by now there was a you
know suspected you know aggressive and
widespread you know attempts to
influence the u.s. presidential election
through russian you know information
operations from WikiLeaks you know email
leaks to cyber attacks and other
measures and what we've seen in germany
are kind of the early signs of something
very similar happening next year germany
is going to be holding their you know
their elections and what we're starting
to see is basically the same type of
tensions that exist between the US and
Russia you know are also there for us in
Germany as well and a lot of this goes
back to Russia's invasion of Ukraine and
the seizing of Crimea you know 2014
after that the US as well as the EU you
know impose really strict sanctions on
Russia
and you know Russian President Putin you
know has not been happy about that and a
lot of this animosity can be traced you
know to to that incident and we've seen
some really interesting stuff happened
in Germany in a sense that's since
that's happened I want to take you back
to one of them that we reported on you
know not too long ago here at Bloomberg
and this was a story we did in 2015
cyberspace becomes the second fresh
second front in Russia's clash with with
NATO and one of the interesting things
we discovered in reporting this story
was that there was a a blast furnace
explosion you know in Germany that was
triggered by a cyber attack and that was
a you know that explosion occurred at
you know a large German firm Tyson krub
and large steel maker I they make
elevators and escalators and and operate
these large steel facilities what
happened was you know a suspected and
well-known russian a hacking group you
know is believed to have been behind
this really kind of rare and
extraordinary event which is the use of
a cyberattack to blow up and disrupt you
know a blast furnace and basically they
caused it to overheat and shut down and
kind of malfunction in the most severe
way one of these things can and the
significance of that is again early
signs of this kind of growing tension
between Russia and Germany being
expressed in cyberspace and what's
happened since then has been pretty
compelling you know there's this really
interesting report that came out of the
Atlantic Council the Kremlin's Trojan
horses Russia has been you know expert
at information operations for a very
long time before you know kind of
hacking even existed in its present form
and what we're starting to see in a lot
of places like the US but also you know
Western Europe and Eastern Europe
certain as well you know are these
information operations that take you
know heavy advantage of the fact that
online it's very hard to tell you know
who's promulgating certain information
so the use of fake identities the east
of hacked information all to promote
certain ideas and there are few places
that we've seen this employed with more
strength and kind of vigor than Germany
right now and this report
goes into a lot of details of that one
of those operations that I wanted to
highlight for you guys is in our
warnings coming out like this these are
these are pretty typical of the the
types of stories coming out of Europe
right now which is you know Germany's
Germany's spy chief is warning that
Russian hackers could tamper with their
election they saw what you know what
happened the u.s. election and they're
picking up they're picking up signs that
this could happen here as well so these
types of stores go into a lot of depth
about the types of attacks that Germans
Germany's intelligence services are
seeing you know and specifically what
their targets are which I'll get to in a
minute which are kind of exclusively
political in nature we've got a couple
of questions coming in so I want to make
sure I get to those first question is
you know what kind of things are they
hacking computers phones apps what's
been happening in these Russian
information operations is you know you
hear a lot from security experts that
you know if you're even if you're a
government intelligence service you
don't necessarily want to hack directly
into your opponent's you know
intelligence service and kind of expose
all of your most sophisticated
capabilities because then you can't use
them anymore so what they do is they
start at a very kind of low level and
they're hacking email phones are a
little bit harder to hack you know so
laptops servers but mostly email like
you know the DNC hacking here in the US
you know that was primarily a fishing
operation which is sending you know
really well-crafted emails to high-level
individuals saying hey you know your
google account has been compromised
click this link and reset your password
really basic stuff but once the
attackers are inside the network they
employ some kind of more sophisticated
tools to extract the information so
regard to this question what are they
hacking email is where they start emails
really always start and the lesson from
this is always if you get an email
that's unsolicited go check it out for
yourself any unsolicited email or the
spam or requests like this from google
just goes research it yourself and if
you think your gmail account has been
compromised go find the official google
link and then reset it yourself don't
click on anything in your email next
question is you know what's the latest
on the DNC hack was it proven that was
Russia you know all signs from the US
telligence community point to it being a
Russian operation now anything like that
involving Russia comes with an asterisk
it comes with a caveat which is you know
from the best that we can tell you know
a lot of the operations out of Russia
hacking operations you know come from
essentially third-party so these are
contract entities you know much like a
defense contractor firm would be in the
US so a third party you know I have kind
of nominally separate from the
government but that does a lot of these
do a lot of these advanced tax so the
best intelligence coming out of the US
you know cyber security community is
that this was very clearly a Russian you
know operation the same malware that was
used throughout Eastern Europe to attack
Russian you know targets of interest
were used to attack the DMC you know the
techniques the command-and-control
servers you know all of the kind of
fingerprints of you know of Russian
operations you know we're there for you
know in the u.s. operation as well you
know all 17 of the US intelligence
agencies have come out in unison and
said we believe this was a Russian
operation you know where there is some
disagreement publicly at this point is
was the operation designed to just
undercut us legitimacy and democratic
legitimacy or was it to elect Donald
Trump there's a lot of disagreement
about that and you know it's unclear if
we'll ever get to a you know a clear
answer on that but what is clear is that
it's very base you know these operations
were designed to undercut the legitimacy
of us elections you know and and promote
the idea that the democratic
institutions in place in the US you know
are not free of corruption either with
another question is you know we've
comment about the vulnerability of
elections in Australia and Canada are
those countries taking precautions to
protect their political systems you know
from cyberattacks you know every country
i think is every major country is taking
a lesson from what we saw in the US
election and you know where as a lot of
cyber security experts intelligence
officials had worried about the security
of election systems you know hacking
hacking the actual voting systems what
we saw in the US was not that and you
know in regular viewers of the show will
know that we've discussed this that you
know those are very hard systems a hack
so that's just not where hackers go
hackers go for the easy kill which are
information operations if you can
provide if you can promulgate enough
false information you know or highlight
hacked information that's disparaging to
your opponent you know that's just much
more powerful in convincing people to do
things you know that kind of that kind
of adhere to your wishes and in this
case you know a trump administration is
obviously much more you know much more
sympathetic shall we say to the you know
the the wishes of the Russian president
so a lot of other countries are taking a
look at that and thinking how do we
counter these massive disinformation
operations it's a hard question to
answer because the technology companies
can do a lot you know to block fake news
and things like that but the fact of the
matter is people who are reading you
know the facebook news feeds watching
our Twitter feeds they're going to see a
lot of this stuff all the time and you
know how do you how do you prevent
voters from being manipulated in this
way is a much harder question than just
a technology one we're getting a lot of
questions today which is great you know
one of these questions was you know why
are there so many hacking reports from
Russia what about other countries surely
they're not the only country with this
ability you know well that's that's
certainly a you know valid concern and
i've asked this to researchers as well
as you know we've seen reports about NSA
hacking it's not often you know outside
of Edward Snowden's disclosures but you
know we see a lot of stuff about Russia
and a lot of stuff from the US about
Russia and there are a few different
reasons for that a couple of the
explanations I've gotten is that you
know the cyber security industry is
based here in the US we have the most
advanced you know cyber security
industry in the world outside of a few
exceptions Israel certainly has a strong
capability and some other countries as
well Russia has some of the best hackers
in the world and the US does as well but
our industry is so strong here that and
so kind of entrenched inside a lot of
companies and government that we just
see a lot and we publicize a lot more
there's a culture of publicizing your
company through the publication of these
reports so we wind up just kind of
seeing this feedback loop of reports
about the same actors it used to be
China you know it that's kind of died
down a little bit with some of the
Accords reached with the Obama
administration and now we're seeing
Russia and there are valid conclusions
to be drawn here that you know Russia
has ramped up a lot of its information
operations
and look at the election here they've
been successful they've been effective
so that's why we're seeing a lot of this
another question is how much of a
concern is electoral hacking
specifically with respect to Russia you
know what percentage of the vote in such
alleged hacking incidents as cast in
doubt well this question gets to the
core of why it's so hard to protect
against these types of attacks you know
because as we've seen with the recount
in you know in Wisconsin and Michigan in
other places you know in some of those
cases you know the president elect Trump
you know wound up getting even more
votes so it's not that you know what
we're not seeing is some sort of
allegation that votes in specific were
manipulated what you're seeing is that
voters were manipulated you know in the
sense of just the amount the sheer
amount of information that was either
false or misleading or kind of just
exaggerated you know through the use of
automated BOTS and things like that you
know common tools of hackers that's a
much harder question to get at because
what you're basically asking is you know
was a voter who was going to vote for
Hillary Clinton you know convinced to
vote for Donald Trump or convinced him
not vote at all by some of this
information that's a pretty deep
psychological question that you know I
haven't seen any good research that gets
to the bottom of if anything that the
consensus view tends to be that beliefs
are reinforced by some of this
information but the idea of vote
flipping you know because of these
information operations much harder
question to get at question here is you
know how can the u.s. spend hundreds of
billions of dollars on security and
intelligence budgets and still be
vulnerable to cyberattacks where's the
money going a good question and the
answer you know was kind of in the
answer I gave not too long ago which is
there's a real problem when the threat
vector or the most vulnerable part of
your system is the user clicking on the
link that they shouldn't it's really
hard to defend against that because what
you have is a user authorizing whoever's
in control of that link they just click
to do stuff to their computer you know
the cyber security industry has really
focused on you know protecting with what
experts called the perimeter which is
you know protecting attackers from kind
of brute forcing their way through your
network we're actually pretty good at
that not perfect but you know the US and
other countries are actually pretty
decent at doing that right now the
problem always becomes what hap
when you have somebody inside the
network doing something they shouldn't
and not because they're knowingly
infecting their network in the case of
the DNC hack it was Hillary Clinton's
you know campaign manager John Podesta
clicking on a google password reset link
that was a malicious link really hard to
protect the gifts Google does its best
to try to flag users when you know
things like that happen but you know
what winds up being some of the best
protection you know winds up being using
two-factor authentication which are text
message alerts to your phone hey is this
really you logging into this account if
so enter this code and that's not a
perfect protection but it's far better
than having none at all and before we
get there last question here you know I
wanted to show one other piece of
information that's come up in regard to
this Germany election issue at the
beginning of december WikiLeaks which
published a lot of the leaked Clinton
emails publish this this was a huge file
of information you know on the German
parliament and specifically it 90
gigabytes of data it's a lot of data 90
gigabytes of data of information on the
German parliament specifically the
German Parliament's investigation into
collusion or cooperation between Germany
and the NSA Germans the Germany spy
chief came out and publicly blamed you
know the leet the theft in the leak of
this data on the same Russian hacking
group that hacked the DNC now subsequent
to that there have been multiple reports
kind of casting doubt on that saying
well maybe it was an insider you know
inside the German parliament so that's
kind of unclear however the early signs
out of Germany was that this operation
as well as an earlier operation into of
hacking into Germany's Parliament we're
the same Russian group that hacked the
DNC so this is something and the point
of this this show really is what we saw
in the US could very well be a prelude
to what we might see in Germany and
elsewhere throughout Europe we focus on
on one country here but other European
nations are also having elections and
you know this issue of Crimea and
Ukraine you know has really has really
fractured you know a lot of very tenuous
alliances around the world and nowhere
so more so than Germany and other
European nation so it's worth it's worth
watching out for
because we may see against similar
behavior you know that happened here
happen elsewhere in the world and this
is a power it's more evidence yet more
evidence of how powerful a weapon
information can be you know when used
maliciously you know and the last
question here is what countries are most
at risk now the answer is really really
any country that's connected to the
Internet you know any country where
there's a large percentage of voters who
consume information over the Internet
this is requiring that you know complete
rethinking of you know how we consume
news and and what's the best way to
consume news and to fact-check things I
mean when you look at your social media
feed you know what most of us do is we
see headlines and occasionally will
click in on something what that means is
you're consuming a lot of information
that you're not checking and really
thinking deeply about and that's just
not the way we've always consumed news
is a relatively new thing and hackers
are exploiting that so you know any
country where their elections and
there's you know widespread use of
social media you know it really requires
voters to rethink you know how they're
interrogating their new sources and
that's a problem that hasn't been solved
yet so you know with that I just wanted
to just want to thank everybody who's
watching again we do this every week you
know 1 p.m. eastern and as always if you
have any questions offline we're more
than happy to its catalog them and try
to answer them in future shows on
twitter i'm at jordan r1000 happy to
taking those questions offline and again
thanks everybody who watch them to
everybody who commented we always
appreciate the engagement and we'll see
we'll see you all next week thanks very
much
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]